sin duda que van a haber cambios hay que
recordar que petro con trans ya marqués
estuvieron aquí en washington dc hace
poco tiempo se reunieron con mucha
cantidad de establishment de los eeuu y
tuvieron un diálogo importante con
intelectuales de la ciudad y kiko gente
que influye en las políticas
internacionales y no cabe duda que pedro
va a intentar mantener una buena
relación con los eeuu no es opositor a
eeuu lo ha dicho claramente pero sí sin
duda que va a querer cambiar un poco el
matiz de esa relación con el países del
norte central o en temas más más
participativos como por ejemplo el tema
medioambiental y alejarse un poco de la
estructura más militarista que impuso el
plan colombia por muchos años así que no
queda duda que petro va a mantener oa
intentar mantener ese esa alianza
estratégica con los eeuu y en ese
sentido se explica porque los eeuu están
apoyando a petro y a francia márquez en
este nuevo período presidencial
histórico para colombiano bueno
justamente usted hablaba del tema
ambiental que es un punto que tienen en
común las políticas del pacto histórico
y las políticas de joe biden que dado
que está entre sus prioridades usted
cree que este podría ser el punto de
partida para este esta reconfiguración
de relaciones así es el tema del
amazonas' este preocupación hay que
recordar que es un tema concreto en los
eeuu se están viendo los efectos del
cambio climático de una manera directa y
dramática bailén justamente está en ese
en ese contexto pero hay que recordar
que también hay otros factores como el
tema de la seguridad que hay que
recordar que colombia todavía es uno de
los productores más grandes de cocaína
de la que se vende en eeuu y otras
drogas así que yo te diría que petro va
a intentar suavizar el matiz de esas
relaciones pero hay temas duros que hay
que resolver de forma urgente no bueno y
mire con colombia se marca una tendencia
latinoamericana hacia la izquierda
después de la elección de gabriel
boliche en chile y con una fuerte
candidatura de lula da silva en brasil
en el período pasado era la derecha la
que predominaba en la región que nos
dice esta alternancia política de la
realidad que vivimos así es no cabe duda
que es un cambio de folio importante hay
que recordar que colombia siempre tuvo
gobiernos conservadores de derecha y yo
te diría que este triunfo claro de petro
aunque aunque no tan holgado pero claro
en el sentido de la implicancia
histórica ganar una elección con la
participación casi del 60 por ciento de
los colombianos dice mucho sobre que
este modelo capitalista y puramente
neoliberal fracasó por lo menos para
colombia en el caso de chile también dos
países muy similares con niveles de
desigualdad crónicos con el nivel de
pobreza bastante importantes hay que
recordar que colombia tiene casi un 40%
de pobreza así que sin duda que este
triunfo de petró es un poco un voto de
censura contra estas políticas más
conservadoras de las últimas décadas